biden struggling to deal with a surge in
crime as the white house tries to
distance itself from the defund the
police movement
the president focusing on guns and
giving covet money to cops while meeting
with big city leaders and law
enforcement officials
this comes after another weekend of
bloodshed four people were reportedly
killed in new york city
and at least 40 were shot and 11 died in
chicago
new york city mayoral candidate eric
adams saying the focus of the meeting
was on
root causes of crime this president is
making it clear
he's going to redefine the ecosystem of
public safety
why did it take so long before
we heard the gunshots that families were
listening
and hearing every night other
communities are waking up to
alarm clocks communities of black brown
and poor people are waking up to gun
shots
and this president said this is not the
america we're going to live in
so if you were paying attention last
week and we know you were
jessica it felt like there was about to
be a pivot in
politics because the polling was
starting to come in the white house was
starting to realize that people like
eric adams are going to win over the
progressives
their their ploy to pin defund the
police on republicans had fallen totally
flat and actually hurt them in the long
run
so now all of a sudden you see this
pivot do tell me about the democrats
positioning right now
and is what president biden did today an
attempt to try to prevent some major
bloodshed in the midterms
i think it's an attempt to prevent some
major bloodshed in the literal sense
and midterms bloodshed i think that this
is something that has mattered to joe
biden over decades
and he made the wrong decision certainly
on things like the crime bill
but it has always been a passion point
for him to be in criminal justice reform
and to talk about it
and i would say it goes back you know
two three weeks is actually when the
polling started dripping in to say this
is a problem which is when we had the
press conference
on gun control and what's going on in
our cities
um i thought it was a good day for the
white house on this for sure i think
eric adams is certainly you know
taking advantage of the new bully pulpit
that he will get in november and
we're going to elect a democrat here and
i liked
the show of you know that we had there
was a female police chief standing there
with him who also
spoke that there are people um from both
sides of the aisle that are like great
let's start let's get down to business
and addressing this all right and so
we'll see if they do something on that
just speaking of um
eric adams this is what he said lawrence
on cnn this weekend about
guns and where the priorities should be
i believe those priorities they really
were
misplaced and it's almost insulting what
we have witnessed over the last
few years many of our presidents they
saw these numbers they knew that the
inner cities particularly where black
brown and poor people lived
they knew they knew they were dealing
with this real crisis
we should have also focused on the
handgun
the numbers of those who are killed by
handguns
are astronomical all right so uh you
have
his comments and his appearance at the
white house today and perhaps a
new approach
maybe i thought it was a disappointment
i expected more from him
he's talked about a lot of the root
causes i don't disagree with him on the
root causes but what are you going to do
right now
second of all this is a local matter
this is not a federal issue
the attempt to federalize this issue is
a problem
he knows what to do it's very simple and
i call it
just a simple justice plan you bring the
da's in
you bring the beat cops in the police
chief
you bling bring in the chief judge you
assign a judge to these cases
and you give them a week you tell the
gangs
just like they want them to turn into
guns you got a week
to clean up your actions and then you
start busting down doors
you get warrants you make sure it's
solid you have one judge that is
assigned to these cases to look at the
evidence
presented they know who the gangs are
the problem is you have a da's that are
allowing
uh people with these weapons charges
back on the street
you got judges that are assigning bail
when people are risk to society so
everybody needs to get on the same page
right here you can talk about root
causes all day but that doesn't solve
the problem right now
now that can prevent it in the future
but how do you stop the bleeding
right now bring everybody to the table
greg one of the things they're doing at
the white house is urging local
officials to use coveted relief funds
in order to pay for more police so
that's like an end run
so that they don't have to actually deal
with the fact that defund the police
hurt them
yes because they're like here's some
covert relief money it does
it goes back to this initial problem why
were they so late on this
and it's their lateness that caused i
don't know how many lives you could
probably count them
uh i don't know thousands i don't i
don't know if you add them all up
um maybe if the guns were made of legos
the democrats would have gone after them
sooner because
we're watching a government that's more
interested in chasing phantoms than
felons and it's probably because it
wasn't going to affect them politically
why did they wait so long because it
wasn't going to affect them politically
and now we on the i don't know for seven
eight months a year were saying this is
a bad thing
and we were laughed at we were laughed
at by people on other networks like don
lemon and chris cuomo going oh the
shooting in the street oh i went out to
a restaurant
i didn't see any crime idiots because
the reason why they couldn't admit there
was a crime problem is because then they
have to admit that they were wrong
and it's a huge huge sunk cost when you
spend
so much time saying that this doesn't
happen
they put so much investment in an
anti-cop narrative
that they can't now admit that it was
wrong
but there is a reason why they do this
and it happens in every political
situation
they only choose the situation based on
what republicans do
so if republicans come out as pro-law
enforcement they instinctively come out
as anti-law enforcement
so if you talk about as a republican
talk about freedom in cuba
then they talk about freedom as a phrase
being anti-government
so you see what's happening here it's a
really stupid professional wrestling
type of a type of uh of debate but they
they can't let go and that's what's
happening right now you're seeing them
try to let go we should actually
encourage them but still pisses me off
that they
didn't do this sooner i'll give you the
floor well when i hear root causes from
democrats that just means they're just
going to run out the clock
joe biden can't actually even articulate
what the issue is
and it is black teenagers and 20 year
olds many without a good education
a dad or a job they are shooting people
with pistols other gang members
over turf and clout and drug profits
stray bullets are
killing innocent people and democrat
da's prosecutors and judges
are making it impossible to incarcerate
these people as you mentioned
i get it i'm a realist there's going to
be street violence in the inner city but
we don't have to be so permissive about
it every time we're so permissive about
crime
crime
explodes and people die joe biden used
to get this
that was his thing and now because of
the left wing animates his base so much
he has to now walk this tightrope he
knows the solution
he won't address the problem trump love
him or hate him he would actually
say what the problem was in really stark
terms
people loved him for that they also
hated him for that
but that's what real leaders do joe
biden's not a real leader especially on
crime here's the problem real quickly
because i know we got to go it's not
just
gun violence that's the problem it's
crime in general the people that feel
like they can just go into stores and
rob
right just urinate on the street it's
the fact that there should be no laws
that the fact that everything is petty
crime criminal justice reform advocates
have said
drug crimes we've said people that are
non-violent offenders should
we should be measured in the way that we
deal with them they believe no one
should be locked up and the only reason
why they're shifting on the issue
is because the polling has changed but
there were people like the chicago
superintendent was there i mean you
never
meet a police yeah he's been silenced by
his mayor he was a great police chief
in dallas he was very enforced and had a
relationship with the community
and the police and now he goes to
chicago and
the mayor has put a muzzle on him i'm
i'm not saying
that there aren't issues with how it
trickles down from higher levels of law
enforcement but you were staring at a
bunch of democrats who are taking
crime very seriously and we were just
talking in the break
about you know we'll see who eric adams
puts in as the police chief that will
tell a lot of the story
of how this is going to go but i just
can't sit here and say you know
democrats don't care about crime i think
a big piece of this also is the
prosecutors
and that's happening hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else